Iraqis under 25 have never known a day
when their country wasn't being bombed
sanctioned or occupied by the United
States
maybe that's why 93 percent of them see
the u.s. as their enemy well initially
American Idol Inara learn how the color
guard is terrible at narrative gr20 a
lot hey I'm Rican culpability lon
so why can't the US quit Iraq
ideological reasons aside Iraq holds a
key strategic location for the u.s. a
location that's filled with oil
resources military bases and pretty
close allies but that's meant different
things over the decades let's start with
1980 when Iraq under Saddam Hussein
launched a war against the newly minted
Islamic Republic of Iran the u.s. jumped
at the opportunity to weaken the
Republic which in 1979 and ousted one of
the us's most loyal allies the shop so
the iran-iraq war became an opportunity
for the u.s. not only to weaken the
Islamic Republic and of anti-american
leader but also to prevent any communist
influence that could enter the region as
a result of losing a major ally the u.s.
gave aid top secret intelligence and
weapons to Iraq throughout the
eight-year war and to make things more
complicated some members of Ronald
Reagan's administration were also
facilitating the secret sales of arms to
Iran during the 80s through Israel the
reason to stay friendly with those in
the Iranian government that seemed
sympathetic to the US now it was also
during this time that the US helped Iraq
develop chemical weapons it later used
against the country's Kurdish minority
and when the United Nations tried to
sanction the Iraqi government for those
abuses it was the u.s. that blocked any
action ultimately the war claimed over 1
million Iraqi and Iranian lives US
interests shifted once again when the
Iraqi military invaded Kuwait in 1990
Iraq accused the oil-rich monarchy of
stealing its petroleum and was coming to
seize what it said was rightfully rocks
that didn't make America too happy
Kuwait was a major supplier of oil to
the US and the Saudis weren't too
excited either they not only shared the
border with Iraq but were also home to
large oil reserves the first Bush
administration worried it wouldn't be
too long until a rock would wanna invade
Saudi Arabia so a us-led coalition
launched op
raishin Desert Storm in 1991 which
consisted of five weeks of aerial
assaults against the Iraqi military and
civilian targets followed by a ground
operation meanwhile the UN imposed harsh
sanctions that crippled the Iraq the
economy and claimed hundreds of
thousands of lives including a reported
half million children those sanctions
lasted throughout the 90s during the
presidency of Bill Clinton who vowed to
remove Saddam Hussein from power Clinton
imposed no-fly zones and military
operations in Iraq the goal was
apparently to protect the Kurds and Shia
Muslims and isolate Saddam to weaken it
but the opposite actually happened
Saddam was able to consolidate his power
in the face of foreign aggression so by
the time the 2003 invasion of Iraq
happened the United States had already
been at war more or less with Iraq for
more than a decade and while the reasons
for the invasion ranged from so-called
weapons of mass destruction to the gift
of democracy we have no ambition in Iraq
except to remove a threat and restore
control of that country to its own
people many speculated from the get-go
that the real reason was again about
Iraq's oil and instead of finding WMDs
the u.s. found itself in a quagmire it
couldn't control and instead of
democracy the u.s. gave Iraqis a civil
war a broken economy the Abu Ghraib
prison unaccountable private contractors
sectarian strife and hundreds of
thousands of dead America also dissolved
the Iraqi army creating a vacuum of up
to 300,000 arms and unemployed men many
of whom would go on to join and build
Isis the same Isis that President Barack
Obama is now trying to degrade and
destroy through bolstering US military
presence once again in Iraq our
objective is clear we will degrade and
ultimately destroy ISIL
so with decades of US military
involvement in their country bringing
little good is it real
a surprise that so many young Iraqis are
just fed up